welcome to my talk today i'll tell you
about counting and sampling perfect
matchings and this is joint work with
farzam and cheyenne
let's start with some notation
in this talk all graphs will be
unweighted and undirected
and all graphs will have an even number
of vertices
let's define m of i to be the set of
matchings containing exactly i edges
and let's define little m of i to be the
cardinality of m of i
notice that when i is equal to n we are
talking about the perfect matchings
for example consider this graph
it has exactly two perfect matching so
little m of n is equal to two
the main algorithmic task we will
consider is that of computing the number
of perfect matchings
valiant famously showed that it's
sharply hard to compute this quantity
exactly even if the graph is bipartite
a natural question is can we
approximately computed
one of the most fruitful techniques to
solve approximate counting problems has
been this equivalence between
approximate counting and approximate
sampling which was shown by jerem
baliant and vazirani
in particular for matchings this result
shows that the existence of an efficient
randomized algorithm to approximate the
number of perfect matchings
is equivalent to the existence of an
approximate sampling algorithm from the
uniform distribution or the set of
perfect matchings
in this direction german sinclair gave
markoff chain based approximate sampling
algorithms that are efficient if the
ratio of the number of n minus 1
matchings to the number of perfect
matchings is small
notice that this does not include the
class of all bipartite graphs but for
example it does include the class of all
dense graphs
where the degree of every vertex is at
least half the number of vertices
germ sinclair and vigora gave efficient
markov chain based approximate sampling
algorithms if g is bipartite
a major open problem in the field of
approximate counting and sampling is
whether we can do the same for every
graph not just bipartite graphs
in our work we show that there are there
exist efficient algorithms for these
tasks in the important special cases
that the graph is a regular expander
before stating the result let me define
an expander
let's suppose that g is a d regular
graph
and let a tilde be the normalized
adjacency matrix of g
clearly the eigenvalues of a tilde must
lie between -1 and 1 with the largest
eigenvalue being exactly equal to 1.
we'll say that the graph g is an epsilon
spectral expander if every other
eigenvalue has magnitude at most epsilon
for example friedman showed that almost
all d regular graphs
are epsilon spectral expanders with
epsilon being around 2 over square root
t
now let me tell you our first result
which is algorithmic
let's say g is a d regular epsilon
spectral expander
then there is an n to the o of log d or
log one over epsilon time randomized
algorithm
for approximate sampling and approximate
counting perfect matchings
let me make some remarks about this
theorem
firstly if epsilon is smaller than an
inverse polynomial in d or if t is a
constant
then the running time of this algorithm
is polynomial
secondly by friedman's theorem this
gives a polynomial time algorithm for
almost every d regular graph
thirdly the results also hold if g is
approximately regular which means all of
its degrees are in theta of d
and fourthly
our theorem requires that epsilon which
is the spectral expansion is smaller
than a fixed constant and this is only
achievable if d is larger than a fixed
constant which is an important caveat of
our theorem
next let's switch gears and talk about a
very different type of result
the van der in conjecture was a theorem
proved by phallic man and engorgive
which states that if g is a d regular
bipartite graph then the number of
perfect matchings
is at least d over e to the n
for reference a trivial upper bound one
can prove on the number of perfect
matchings is d to the n
a natural question is whether we can
prove similar types of results for
classes of non-bipartite graphs
this inspired the low ash plumber
conjecture from 86
which conjectures that if g is a d
regular d minus 1 edge connected graph
then the number of perfect matchings in
g is at least some constant based on d
times some other constant based on d to
the n
where these constants are positive such
that
c prime of d goes to infinity as d goes
to infinity
recall that a graph is d minus 1 edge
connected if its min cut is at least d
minus 1.
ideally for a strong version of this
conjecture we would want c prime d to be
at least some polynomial in d
or optimally we want c prime d to be d
over e
so far the lowest power conjecture is
still open
the best partial result we have is one
by s split and others we show that we
can get c prime d to be a constant which
is slightly larger than one
notice that c prime d doesn't vary with
t in this
result
the work of polo bash and mckay shows
similar results for randomly regular
graphs
in particular
their work implies that the number of
perfect matchings in a random detailed
graph is essentially at least d over e
to the n
with probability one minus inverse
polynomial in d
notably this only holds if d is small
enough compared to n
now let me state our second theorem
we show that if g is a d regular epsilon
spectral expander then the number of
perfect matchings in g is at least d
over e to the n times this error term
this error term can be shown to be
negligible compared to the first term if
epsilon is small enough
if one views expansion as a
strengthening of edge connectivity
then our result can be seen as a partial
resolution of the lowest power
conjecture in the special case that g is
a expander
next take d to be a random d regular
graph
freedman's theorem implies that with
probability 1 minus inverse polynomial
in n
epsilon is smaller than an inverse
polynomial in d
which means that with the same
probability
the error term in the above theorem is
negligible
therefore with high probability in
random d regular graphs the number of
perfect matchings is essentially at
least d over e to the n
this can be seen as an improvement over
borowash and mckay's result
whose work only implies any bound on
little m of n
with high probability with respect to d
as our result implies a bound on little
m of n with high probability with
respect to n
next i will give an overview of how we
prove our two results
for the rest of the stock let g be a d
regular epsilon spectral expander on two
n vertices
our main technical level is the
following
let k be an integer
then the ratio of the number of k
matchings to the number of k plus 1
matchings is upper bounded by this
quantity on the right
to get some intuition about the right
hand side of this inequality
let's plug in some different values of k
if we start with k equals n minus 1
then the lemma says that the ratio of
the n minus 1 matching to the number of
perfect matchings
is at most n to the o of log d or log
one over epsilon
you might recall that this is the same
as the running time of our
algorithm from theorem one
on the other hand if we plug in k to be
slightly smaller
at one minus epsilon times n then the
main level shows that the ratio of k
matchings to k plus 1 matchings
is at most a polynomial in d
notice how rapidly the upper bound has
improved from k being close to n to k
being close to n times 1 minus epsilon
this lemma can be used to show both our
theorems
let's start with how it implies the
first theorem
which is the algorithmic one
called this result of german sinclair
who showed that we can count or sample
perfect matchings approximately
in time polynomial and n and the ratio
of the number of n minus 1 matchings to
the number of perfect matchings
as in the previous slide let's apply our
main lemma with k set to n minus 1.
this implies that the ratio above is at
most n to the o of log d or log of 1
over epsilon which directly implies that
their algorithm runs in
the required required time
next let me say why the main implies
theorem 2 which is a lower bound on the
number of perfect matchings
the first step in our argument is to
show a strong lower bound on the number
of matchings of size 1 minus epsilon
times n
the reason such a bound can be true is
because the expander mixing lemma shows
that for any matching of size at most 1
minus epsilon times n
there must be an unmatched vertex
with a substantial fraction of its
neighbors being still unmatched
the second step in our argument is to
show a lower bound on the ratio m of n
to m of 1 minus epsilon times n
this can be shown by multiplying the
main lemma
for all k between 1 minus epsilon times
n and n
to complete the proof of the theorem we
can simply multiply the inequalities in
step one and step two
notice that most of the error in the
theorem comes from step two
it remains to argue why this main
technical lemma is true
for simplicity let's assume k is equal
to n minus 1
so the main level turns into the
following statement
by some arguments from the literature
like those in german sinclair's paper it
suffices to prove the lemma at the
bottom
which says that for any matching of size
n minus 1
there exists an augmenting path of
length that's bounded by
log base 1 over epsilon of n
recall that an augmenting path for m is
any alternating path for m which begins
and ends at an unmatched vertex
take this example if this is a matching
m
and here is an augmenting path for this
matching
for the rest of this talk we will show
how to prove this lemma
it says that any matching of size n
minus 1 has a short augmenting power
we'll use a result from tanner which
says that if g is an epsilon spectral
expander then it's essentially a one
over epsilon vertex expander
let me start by making the additional
assumption that g is bipartite
then it turns out the lemma has a pretty
simple argument through alternating bfs
let me tell you what i mean by that
so let's consider the following
bipartite graph
and a matching m of size n minus 1.
our goal is to show that there exists a
short augmenting path in this graph that
is there exists a short alternating path
from s to t in this graph
let's construct a sequence of subsets of
the bottom partition of this graph
starting with b1 which is the
neighborhood of s
next
let's look at the set of the matched
neighbors of b1
next let's look at the neighborhood of
this set
which we can call b2
we are going to repeat this operation
until our set bi contains the vertex t
it's not too hard to convince yourself
that since the graph is a one over
epsilon vertex expander the size of bi
is increasing with every iteration
and that the number of iterations before
bi contains every vertex in the bottom
partition is at most
log n base 1 over epsilon
next it's easy to see that bi by
definition of bi is exactly equal to the
set of vertices reachable from s by an
alternating walk of length at most i
and since the graph is bipartite we can
shortcut all these alternating walks and
we get that bi is equal to the set of
vertices reachable by an alternating
path of length at most i
since t is in bi for i being
approximately log base 1 over epsilon n
this shows that there is an alternating
path from s to t of length at most log
base 1 over epsilon n
this completes the proof of the lemma in
the bipartite case
what if g is not bipartite can we adapt
the argument from before to work in this
case
this turns out to be a very difficult
task and one of the ways to see this
is to see that alternating walks cannot
be shortcut to alternating paths in
non-bipartite graphs
for example this is a non-bipartite
graph
and it does have an alternating walk
from std
but it's easy to see that this graph has
no alternating path from s to t
this was one of the crucial steps of the
proof in the bipartite case and it seems
hard to get around this in the
non-bipartite case
so it seems that we need a new idea
the main idea of our proof is the
following
instead of trying to run the bipartite
analysis on the non-bipartite graph g
let's take a random bipartite sub graph
of g and try to run the analysis on this
sub graph
if we get that with non-zero probability
this bipartite subgraph has a short
augmenting path this would imply that
the original graph also has a short
augmenting path
let me tell you how we construct our
random bipartite sub graph
for example take this graph g where the
orange edges are the matching m
let's orient each edge in the matching
arbitrarily
these orientations are signified by the
arrow heads on the edges
now let me see how the bio partition is
created
i'm going to separate the two halves of
the bipartition by this blue line
first let's arbitrarily place the
unmatched vertices one on each side of
the
bipartition next for each matching edge
pick a random direction either left or
right
if the direction is left
then assign the two endpoints of the
matching edge to opposite bipartitions
such that the arrowhead faces the left
and if the random direction is right
then do the same but making sure that
the arrowhead faces the right instead
once we do this for all the matching
edges we have obtained a bipartition of
the graph
let omega be the set of n minus 1 random
coins we flip to get to this partition
and let g of omega
be the bipartite graph you get after
deleting all edges that go from one
partition to itself
notice that g of omega still completely
contains the matching m
because for each matching edge we place
its endpoints in opposite partitions
since g of omega is always a sub graph
of g
it suffices to show that the lemma is
true with probability more than zero
over the randomness omega
here is why we might expect the lemma to
be true for g of omega with non-zero
probability
we know that g is a vertex expander from
10 as result
and the following argument shows that g
of omega is a slightly worse vertex
expander in expectation
here's what i mean by that
consider set s and g we know that since
g is a good vertex expander
the neighborhood of s is large
now consider a random bipartition of g
and for simplicity assume that s is all
on the left of the spy partition
after deleting all the inner partition
edges we see that about half of the
vertices which were originally neighbors
of s but outside of s still remain
neighbors of
s notice that g of omega is not likely
to be a good vertex expanded for all
sets
but at least for individual sets we are
able to show that they are likely to
expand
this raises the question of whether all
the sets that we encountered during the
approximately login iterations of
alternating bfs are likely to expand
simultaneously
perhaps you can take a union bound over
all these sets
unfortunately this turns out to not
provide a strong enough bound
so we need to do a more careful analysis
this ends up being a bit tricky because
there are dependencies between whether
different sets expand
and our main technical contribution is
how to account for these dependencies
using this we are able to show that the
lemma holds with non-zero probability
over the omegas
completing the proof of the level
i will conclude with some future
directions
firstly recall that our two results
made use of the fact that epsilon the
spectral expansion was
close to zero
one natural question is whether similar
results are possible with weaker
expansion for example if epsilon is
closer to one
or perhaps using only one sided
expansion
along these lines we conjecture that
similar results are possible
using conductance instead of spectral
expansion
another question is whether we can
utilize this idea of random bipartitions
in a stronger way
in particular maybe we can reduce the
problem of counting number of perfect
matchings in general graphs
to counting the number of perfect
matchings in a random bypartition
the latter task is something we are able
to do efficiently due to the algorithm
of germ sinclair and vicoda
so it might be conceivable to estimate
the average number of perfect matchings
across random bipartitions perhaps using
a markov chain or by partitions and then
using this to compute an estimate of the
number of perfect matchings
finally the low wash plumber conjecture
on d regular d minus 1 edge connected
graphs are still open
a solution to this conjecture might also
need two insights that give
approximation algorithms for the number
of perfect matchings in these graphs
which are not currently known
this is the end of the dock and thank
you for your time